hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers clipper who asks hi
evan is clipper
I would love a bit more detail about how
to build that business around the
customer PS I have new goal to crop pass
with you and shake your hand and thank
you
well Thank You Clifford for the kind
words and if you're in Toronto I'd love
to grab a coffee and shake your hand to
answer your question about how to build
a business around a customer it's one of
my favorite piece of advice for
entrepreneurs because if you can build
around the paying customer then your
chances of success are much higher if
you have money coming in and you know
you have a customer who likes what you
do is willing to pay you for it so
that's the first step to getting your
business started in order to make that
happen you need to start connecting
whether we've had your customers and
finding out what their main challenges
are so there's a number of ways to do it
but you start by hanging out where your
potential customers are hanging out
so there's networking events or
different conferences or different
meetings that you know your potential
customers are gonna be at you want to go
there you can also look online there's
an forums or on Twitter or Facebook or
LinkedIn groups where you know that your
customers are hanging out you want to be
there and you want them to start to get
to know you as you start talking to them
it hasn't introduced yourself you're not
selling anything yet all you're trying
to do is add as much value to them as
possible and try to help them out get
them to think hey this guy knows what
he's talking about and can potentially
help me then as you start building that
relationship with them you ask some of
the challenges that they're facing and
then they'll come up into the course of
conversation find out what problems
they're facing and hopefully there's
something in there that you can work out
a solution to and you can ask them yeah
I understand that's a huge challenge for
you if I were able to help you do XYZ
would that make sense for you and as you
get to know these people and as they
build up confidence with you then there
more likely to want to come aboard and
work with you and it's really as simple
as that it's trying to get to know as
many people as you can who are potential
customers find out about the challenges
that they're facing and try to be as
helpful and valuable as possible at the
started relationship to develop rapport
and to really start to get to know some
where their challenges and once you hit
on a challenge that you think you can
really help them solve work with them to
solve that problem and it's a start of
your new business so I hope that helps
Clifford if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below and I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
and stay tuned for the next episode
you